البوم عن انفجارات وقتل في قاعده الجويه
استراتيجيه داخل روسيا وسلطات الروسيه
تتحقق
طالبان تتجاهل التمديد الدولي وتقول انها
لن تتراجع عن قرارها حتى لو تعرضت لقنبله
الذريه
العواصف الثلجيه التي تضرب شرق الولايات
المتحده تخلف 34 قتيلا وولايه نيويورك
الاكثر تظهرها
[موسيقى]
اسعد الله صباحكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الانباء من العربيه
من الخطوط الاماميه في اوكرانيا بينما قال
حاكم منطقه الروسيه انه يجري التحقق من
هذه الانباء في قاعده انجلت اوضحت مصادر
انا الانفجارات خلفت ثلاثه قتل على الاقل
وعددا من الجرح
الى ذلك صرح نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
بمتر مادبادف بان العالم على شفا حرب
عالميه ثالثه وكارثه نوويه اذا لم تحصل
موسكو على ضمانات امنيه تناسبها
ستفعل كل شيء لمنع حصوله
بين روسيا والغرب اكثر بكثير مما يجمع
بينهم وكان العام الماضي نقطه تحول
قبل ذلك كذا الرئيس الروسي فلاديميه
بوتينا ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض بشان حلول
مقبوله مع جميع اطراف الصراع في اوكرانيا
لكنه اكد انهم رفضوا ذلك
السياسيه ورغبه الخصوم
ميخائيل بطوله
الريس ابراهيم
كلمه لمواطنه بمناسبه انتهاء العام هكذا
خلالها على ان الضربات الروسيه لمصادر
الطاقه الاوكرانيه لم تمنعهم من الحاق
الخسائر بالقوات الروسيه
يحاول جعل هذه الايام مظلمه وصعبه بالنسبه
لنا لقد خسرت روسيا كل ما في وسعها هذا
العام لكنها تحاول تعويض خسائرها بالشماته
وذلك بعد الضربات الصاروخيه على قطاع
الطاقه لدينا اعلم ان الظلام لن يمنعنا من
تكبير الغازات هزائمه جديده لكن يجب ان
نكون مستعدين لاي سيناريو
في افغانستان على لجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
تعليق برامجها هناك على خلفيه حضرتك عمل
النساء في جميع المنظمات غير الحكوميه في
البلاد
وحضرت اللجنه التي تعمل فيها افغانستان
منذ عام
1988 مننا قرار طالبان ستكون له عواقب
وخيبه على الشعب الافغاني
اوقفت عملها في البلاد وهي انقذ الاطفال
للمساعدات التي تنقذ الارواح
[موسيقى]
وفي خضم تجديد الدوليه واسعه كده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بان قرار طالبان سيعطل
تسليم المساعدات وقد يكونوا مدمرا
لافغانستان
اشعر بقلق عميق من ان حظر طالبان مساهمه
النساء في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
افغانستان سيؤدي الى تعطيل المساعدات
الحيويه والمنقذه لحياه الملايين
باسم
الخارجيه ان حركه طالبان بقرارها منع نساء
بين التوظيف المنظمات غير الحكوميه ستعزر
نفسها عن الشعب الافغاني والمجتمع الدولي
لطيفا ان الولايات المتحده ستبحث مع
حلفائها وشركائها لتحديد الرد الانسب على
قرارات طالبه كل هذه القرارات فعلا تؤدي
الى زياده الاصل طالما من المجتمع الدولي
ومن سكان اذن نعم كما قلت الان كمان نرى
في الافغانستان همم هذا ليس ال ال ال
السبب او ليس مسؤوليه للشعب سنه
هي التي تاخذ كل هذه القرار همم الولايات
المتحده لدينا بعد الاليات واسمعنا منذ
ايام من وزير يمكن ان نحن الان سنبحث من
الخلفاءنا وشركاؤنا بالاصبع
طب وسيله لارسل رساله واضحه للي تعليمات
حول هذه القرارات
وفي بروكسل دينامو سياسه الخارجيه في
الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف اوريل بشده قراره
حكومه طالبات بمنع نساء من العمل في جميع
المنظمات غير الحكوميه المحليه والاجنبيه
وقال ان هذا يرقى الى محو النساء من
المجالات العامه
شعر بالفزع من القرار الاخير الذي جاء بعد
منع الطالبات من دخول الجامعات الاسبوع
الماضي وحتى بريل طالبان على التراجع فورا
عن قرارها في اطار التزامها باحترام
القانون الانساني الدولي
الانسانيه قال في بيان للمنظمه انه سيتعين
على الاتحاد الاوروبي والجهاز الاخرى التي
تقدم المساعدات لشعبها افغانستان ان النظر
في طبيعتها هذا القرار والقرار الذي
اتخذته طالبان باغلاق الجامعات تماما
النساء على تعاملهم مع بلداننا ومنظمات
[موسيقى]
تتواصل فقد عبر الامير العامل منظمه
التعاون الاسلاميه
قال المتحدث باسم الطالب بان ذبيح الله
مجاهد ردا على اداله واشنطن منع عمل
المراه في المنظمات الحكوميه قال اين
طالبان ترفضوا اي تهديد على خلفيه
قراراتها المتعلقه بالنساء كما ترفض تدخل
الولايات المتحده في شؤونها وفي المنظمات
العامله في افغانستان
محمد نجيب ان الحركه لن تتراجع عن
قراراتها تجاه النساء حتى لو القي عليهم
قنبله
ذريهما وصفه بالاملاءات من اي شخص في ما
يتعلقوا بحقوق المراه
هندخله
مروه احدى طالبات التي تاثرنا بقرار منعهم
من التعليم كانت على بعدي بضعه ياشور فقط
من ان تصبح اول امراه في عائلتها تلتحق
بالجامعه
بينما يذهب شقيقها وحيدا الى الجامعه
بدونها
داخل هذا المكان
كبرت احلام
وقبرت اخرى في بلاد تعاني فيها النساء من
نيل حتى ابسط حقوقهن
اختيار زياده
لا استطيع ان اصف بالكلمات ما شعرت به في
اليوم الذي تلقيت فيه تلك الاخبار حتى لو
قرروا قطع رؤوس النساء لكان افضل من هذا
الحظر
خوف وياس ومستقبل مجهول
هكذا حياتهن خارج دائره الزمن بفعل قرار
من طالبان
الى جانبه وان تنجح وتنضي قدما رغم العديد
من المشاكل
انا سعيده
لكن من ناحيه اخرى اشعر بالحزن ان ابنتي
غير قادره على فعل شيء نفسه اذا لم تحقق
نتيجه
طالبان دون اقتراس باضراره الكارثيه
الحاليه والمستقبليه في مواصله لاسلوبها
الدائم في تجهيل النساء
المؤسسه الخيريه للزعيم الافغانيه الراحل
احمد شاه مسعود اعلنت اطلاق مدرسه على
الانترنت
لتحت الفرصه للفتيات الافغانيات لاستكمال
دراستهم قال زعيم وجبهه المقاومه احمد
مسعود ابن الزعيم الراحل احمد شاه مسعود
الى اطلاق مدرسه على الانترنت يرمي
لمواجهه الحظر الشامل الذي تفرضه طالبان
على تعليم المراه
مسعود اطلق واسم كل بيت ومدرسه
وبين الاحتجاج في الشارع ورفع شعارات
تعددت اوجه الاعتراض على قرار طالبان منع
الفتيات من التعليم الجامعي
افغانيتان وجدنا الغناء وسيله لتعبير
[موسيقى]
هشام
كفاله زمان
[موسيقى]
زبانه رزمه
الايراني
جول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حامل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حكم
الصحه العالميه تقول للعربيه انها لا
تنصحوا بجرعات لقاح اضافيه
طرقات الرئيسيه في المدينه بسواتر
الترابيه واحرق الاطارات المطاطيه احتجاجا
على تغول الميليشيات المسلحه الخارج عن
القانون وسيطرتها على مناطق المدينه
وطالبين بفتح تحقيق ومحاسبه المتورطين في
الجريمه وبتعزيز الامر
سياسيه نقله تلفزيون ليبيا الحادثه عن
رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد المشرق
قوله انه من الممكن اجراء الانتخابات في
البلاد قبل اكتوبر العام المقبل اذا جرى
اقرار القاعده الدستوريه قريبا
شوط كبير مع مجلس النواب فيما يتعلق
باعداد القاعده الدستوريه واضاف ان مجلس
الدوله سيقرر اليوم موقفه من استئناف
الحوار مع مجلس النواب بعد ايقاف البرلمان
قانون المحكمه الدستوريه
المقومات
في اليمن قال رئيس قسم الغسيل الكلوي في
مستشفى الثوره العام بتعز الدكتور فهمي
الحناني في لقاء مع العربيه ان اكثر من
2006 في المستشفى يحتاجون لغسيل الكره
اليوم اكثر من 88 مريض فش له كلوي بحاجه
الى الغسيل ومن لدينا اكثر 260 مريض
مسجلين في سجلتها المركز يحتاجون الى
الغسيل بشكل مستمر طبعا توقف ماده الديزل
على مرضى الفشل الكلوي ليس للمره الاولى
ولكن هذه اكثر من مره بسبب عدم وجود
ميزانيه كافيه لتشغيل همم المستشفى بشكل
عام لان ال- همم الميزانيه المعتمده يا
دوب 10 ملايين الريال
وفاء التقديريه الشهريه تصل الى 60 مليون
فطبعا هذه المبالغ لم نستطيع همم توفيرها
مش اول مره عده مرات
يملونه بالديزل ورق بكرت الصباح شنو غسل
الي يرسموم مليان سوائل ما في جيزان
اعلنت المدعيه العامه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
العربيه رصدت اثار الشغب بين الجليه
الكرديه والشرطه الفرنسيه في باريس
متناقضان للحياه الفارسيه صفوف طويله لمن
ينتظرون الدخول الى سيرك الشتاء التاريخي
لمشاهده عروض متنوعه وعلى بعد امطار سمحت
هدوء ما بعد العاصفه لسكان الحي والعابرين
فيه بمعاينه الاضرار سيارات قلبت او احرقت
وواجهات زجاجيه تحطمت جزئيا وغضب كردي
تفجر بعد ان اقدم يمني متطرف اقر بعنصريته
على قتل ثلاثه اكراد وجرح ثلاثه اخرين
صباح الجمعه اقر المعتدي ايضا انه توجه
صباح الجمعه الى ضاحيه سند حيث اراد قتله
اكبر عدد من المهاجرين لكن قله عدد الناس
في الشارع دفعته للعوده الى باريس حيث
اقدم على جريرته الثلاثيه حصيله المواجهات
واحد وثلاثون شرطيا جرحوا وجرح متظاهر
واحد على المسؤولون الاكراد الغاضبين الى
الهدوء في ما قال وزير العدل الفرنسي
مطمئنا الاكراد ان فرنسا كلها في عزاء وان
دعمنا لكم ثابت لا يتزعزع
تواجه المقاطعه صناعيه في الصين اصابات
مرتفعه بفيروس كورونا وصلت الى المليون
يوميا من المتوقع ان تتضاعف وافقا حكومه
المقاطعه وضع هذا الارتفاع بالاصابات ذكرت
السيره انه لا توجد وفيات في البر الرئيسي
للايام الخمسه الماضيه واصبحت الارقام على
صعيد الصين غير مكتمله بعد ما توقفت لجنه
الصحه وطنيه عن الابلاغ عن اعداد الاصابات
مما يجعل من الصعب تتبع الحاله
هذا الاسبوع افضل بكثير من الاسبوع الماضي
لقد بلغ ذروته في الثانيه عشر من الشهر
الجاري عند مصطفى حوالي 240 الى 350 شخصا
خارج المستشفى لتلقي العلاج والان العدد
يتراوح بين 240 و250 كان الناس ينتظرون
حوالي ثلاث الى اربع ساعات الان يستغرق
الامر حواليا نصف ساعه
رابعه عوده فيروس كورونا للانتشار في
الصين مجددا اوضحت منظمه الصحه العالميه
للعربيه
وانها لا تنصحه بجرعات اضافيه من اللقاحات
الجامعه حتى الان
اخذ اجراءات اضافيه الى
الاشخاص محددين الذين لديهم امراض تغتصب
المناعه الذين يثبت ان مناعته منخفضه بشكل
كبير حتى لو كان
حصولهم على لقاحات من قبل ولكن اللقاء
بشكل عام جماعي كجرعاه ثالثه ورابعها
لحقيقه لا ينصح للجميع باستعمله
في الولايات المتحده تسببت عاصفه ثلجيه
رافقتها
34 شخصا على الاقل في ثمانيه
انقطاع الكهرباء عن حوالي مليون مره
في رحلات الجويه
[موسيقى]
وفي الخطاب هذا تفكيرهم يا ابرار العالم
انفجارات وقتلى في قاعده جويه استراتيجيات
داخل روسيا وسلطات الروسيه تتحقق
طالبات تتجاهل التمديد الدولي وتقول انها
لن تتراجع عن قرارها حتى لو تعرضت لقنبله
ذريه
العواصف الثلجيه التي تضرب شرق الولايات
المتحده تخلف اربعه 34 قتيلا
ولايه نيويورك الاكثر تضربا
المزيد بعد قليل على شاشه العربيه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]